dit regardez ce que je viens de trouver
c'est navrant
n'auriez pas pu découvrir autre chose
non
[Musique]
à
on commence cette semaine par une bonne
référence franco française appelle quoi
la belge attend moulinsart les dupond
dupont c'est monte c'est pas parce qu'il
a pas une baguette
eric n'est pas france est un vous
connaissez cet étrange sentiment qui va
se passer quelque chose d'horrible du
genre en voyant la boîte mais si ici
vous le connaissez c'est ce sentiment
vous allez jouer à une vraie horreur un
jeu de plateforme aux à essence est
tombé dans le vide et mourir dans des
endroits improbables et bien [ __ ]
mouilleur vous aviez raison ce jeu est
comme une espèce de punition cruelle que
vous infligez riez ont tiré un concentré
de tout ce qu'il ya de pire dans les
jeux de plateforme bien qu'au premier
niveau regarder ça et là je dois aller
prendre l'avion au dessus des
locomotives mais pourtant je peux pas y
aller je veux pas sauter assez loin j'ai
passé au moins 30 minutes à essayer
avant de comprendre que ce petit machin
qu'on voit là est en fait je vous
informe sur lequel on peut sauter non
mais sérieux commenté censé savoir que
si une plate forme alors que ça
exactement la même tête que le reste de
retour à l'hôtel je dois aller chercher
une lettre à la réception pendant que
les chiens les cuisiniers et les femmes
de ménage et c'est de me tuer
probablement le pire hôtel qui existent
au monde et la volaille
c'est typique voilà comment je passe ses
cuisiniers ça me faire toucher
je ne peux pas avancer au premier plan
ils sont trop grands pour sauter par
dessus j'ai juste à passer dessus et à
me faire tuer et en plus tu vois la même
campagne de gambe et sans sérieux c'est
maintenant c'est exactement de ça dont
je veux parler
ce jeu est un concentré de frustration
et d'action et coire entend maintenant
impossible à réaliser
millions de mille sabords
après avoir évité les cuisiniers tueur
j'arrive à l'accueil pour longtemps pour
dire qu'il avait déjà confié la lettre
au capitaine tu pouvais pas le dire
avant [ __ ] d'alcool y est peut-être le
whisky janvier mort qu'elle dédie le
nouvel ouais enfin vu que ta danse avec
un grand sourire sa paire de vraiment de
faire chier un en route pour les pales
donc vous savez c'est vraiment là qu'on
commence à comprendre que quelque chose
notre et non pas dans ce jeu je veux
dire qu'un chien te fasse mal je veux
bien croire un peu mais là mais regarder
mais pourquoi est ce que perdent même
leur frappés par une clochette
comment une clochette qui pèse 18 à 2
grammes peut tuer un homme de 25 ans
[Musique]
donc je trouve un gamin qui va indiquer
le chemin il me demande de le suivre il
faut pas par là tant mieux c'est moins
loin
allociné ou suivant d'aller mais il est
où là il aller à gauche pourtant
[Musique]
on peut parler un peu de l'esprit du jeu
il n'y a pas de souci les graphismes me
rendent assez bien l'univers de la bande
dessinée d'hergé et l'histoire essaye de
suivre relativement le déroulement de la
bande dessinée mais il ya des fois où
vraiment c'est carrément trop vous vous
souvenez de 700 films ou le capitaine
haddock dévale une pente est repassé à
gauche des statuts parce que la droite
sa forme à leur gauche à droite est
différent
[Musique]
la côte d'ivoire
d'ailleurs la même chose dans le jeu
sauf que la pensée 20 km de long et 450
statut à passer [ __ ] ça valait bien la
peine de monter si haut oh [ __ ] le
caillou je contrôle que dalle oh là là
je comprends rien
et merde suis passé à gauche
i
mon dieu croit il était vraiment sucre à
qui l'on connait ce jeu ce jeu est un
festival la difficulté pour passer les
différents niveaux est vraiment
légendaire c'est juste juste impossible
et encore je joue en mode facile et
comme si ça suffisait pas il ya un mot
de passe seulement tous les cinq niveaux
mais pourquoi tous les cinq niveaux
pourquoi pas à tous les lever vous
trouvez pas le jeu déjà c'est impossible
comme ça sérieusement est-ce que les
développeurs était juste trop feignants
pour mettre un mot de passe à chaque
lebel [ __ ] regardez ça mais c'est
juste irréalisable est ce que ce jeu a
vraiment été conçu pour des gamins qui
regardent les aventures de tintin sur
france 3 comment est-ce qu'un gosse de
10 ans peut réussir à finir ce jeu alors
que moi même je n'y arrive pas
pourquoi ces crétins saint-seine mes
amis ma bande sommes toujours au début
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un gouffre dans
un avion pourquoi ce jeu est il si cruel
regarder simple si vous ne tombez pas
exactement pile au milieu des
plateformes vont passer au travers plus
l'histoire du jeu avance et plus on
progresse dans l'irréalisable la regarde
et je dois me servir du vent pour sauter
plus loin et quand j'arrive à la fin de
vie à rien aucun moyen d'aller plus loin
le pur les marches mes couilles et j'ai
plus qu'à me suicider une bien triste
fin après avoir escaladé l'himalaya bon
je suppose qu'il offrait alors sauté en
face et décoché deux piolets en même
temps mais [ __ ] mais pourquoi est-ce
que ça doit être signé mais c'est que le
jeu c'est pas une simulation pour pilote
de chasse prenez la corde de la part des
dons pour avoir jouer à ce jeux
merdiques
vraiment je ne peux pas aller plus loin
je suis désolé j'ai passé tellement de
temps à jouer que je commence à en rêver
la nuit
il est temps d'en finir
[Musique]
en est vraiment faire
e